and for more we're joined by dr.
Sebastian crawl up the head of
management consulting at Accenture
health in Germany and also a doctor off
this is LG so you're putting people to
sleep temporarily yes okay now after
seeing this report would you like to be
a patient in a German hospital yeah
absolutely so it's all okay even
privatized hospitals there's no problem
therefore you know actually the the
quality they are in privatized hospitals
more often it's more better than in not
in privatized but basically yeah it's
still a good place to be in a German
hospital okay but that's good news
because Germans me too we pay a lot of
money for health insurance and so
obviously we hope that we get good
treatment when we go to hospital but we
hear more and more often stories about
patients feeling neglected by the
nursing staff so something seems to be
going wrong well there's a u2
transformation going on in the German
hats gala in the global health
consistent and especially on of course
in the German one too so we are coming
from all around a general approach of
treatment to more specific difference
they should more personalized approach
which means the the length of stay is
getting shorter and that's why the
nursery is getting short children at
accenture health consulting you're
working with a lot of international
client so you have a pretty good idea
about health care systems and other
parts of the world
what could Germany perhaps learn well
basically like I told you before we're
not doing any bad job but let's some
keep your eyes like the money the amount
of money we're spending or like I told
you before the average length of stay
that's quite a little bit of room to to
the benchmark no other countries are
doing a better job there okay it feels a
bit funny talking about a benchmark when
we talk about a person's health but
thank you very much for the moment don't
go well we'll be talking to you in just
a minute but first let's do have a quick
look at how healthcare works in other
countries health costs money but even if
health care is expensive it doesn't
always mean it's the best
the u.s. spends the most on its health
system over 17% of its GDP France and
Germany spend the most in the EU
globally Norway and Japan both managed
on a lot less German hospitals cost 77
billion euros alone critics say there
are simply too many there are eight
hospital beds per 1000 inhabitants in
Germany in Norway which many consider a
model to be emulated on the health front
the figure is exactly half of that the
duration of a hospital stay also
contributes to overall efficiency in
this regard Germany has made progress
the average hospital stay in a German
hospital has decreased to seven point
six days in the past 20 years in Norway
the average stay is six days I will back
again with dr. Sebastian Coulomb and
looking at those figures right at the
end I can't held wonder shouldn't
patients stay in hospital for as long as
they need to I am of course they always
should stay as long as they need to but
as we can see the Germans that well it's
it's the way of the treatment determines
it so like what we are seeing in the
northern countries when they will of
four days I mean people are ready to go
in many other states like sometimes in
Germany you see them within the first
two or three days doing you know doing
tests looking for for results and that's
not the most efficient way that's not
always necessary you're saying no very
surprisingly to many here in Germany
certainly is that the United States is
spending an awful lot of money on health
care you've worked at a u.s. Hospital
how do the two compare the way we treat
in in Germany is we don't look as much
on the money as I liked in yesterday
it's an SUV don't especially we don't
look at much on insurance state like in
the US so staying in a German hospital
from the from the money point of view is
a better place to stay okay and perhaps
just briefly I mean Germany is getting
older and there are already some
bottlenecks and some hospitals
especially in big cities so what's the
future of German hospitals less
hospitals more specialized well
connected and in like in a big network
working
with better calm okay dr. Sebastian call
up thank you very much for joining us
today